-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags"!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
With Halloween coming up,
I started a hashtag called
#NewHalloweenTraditions.
And I asked you guys to tweet
out some new ideas
for Halloween that are
more appropriate for 2020.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along,
everyone.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
new Halloween traditions
responses from you guys.
This first one is from
@changethebee.
B-E-E.
-[ Buzzing ]
Change the Bee.
-Wow.
-Hmm.
Um...
like Chance the Rapper.
-Oh, yeah.
-Change the Bee.
-Change the bee.
-Yeah.
-A bee whose name is Change.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-She says...
"Putting on
your costume and realizing
it's the first time
you've used a zipper all year."
[ Laughter ]
Ah...
This one's from @kblancf.
She says, "A black cat
crossing your path
is now good luck because it
means you went outside at least
once this week."
[ Laughter ]
Got to get the steps in, man.
This one is from @kemitorano.
She says, "Dyeing
hand sanitizer red
to make the kids wash
their hands in 'ghoul's blood'
before each house."
[ Laughter ]
That's good idea.
-Yeah, that's a great idea.
-I like that. Yeah.
This one's from
@Andwejigglelike.
[ Laughter ]
She says, "Instead of dressing
up as zombies, we all dress up
as ourselves because it's pretty
much the same thing now."
[ Laughter ]
Easy costume.
This one's from @ghost7.
They say, "This year's
group costume --
person, woman, man,
camera, TV."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's --
That's the winner right there.
-Yeah.
-This one's from
@Krystal-Pistil.
She says, "Candy cigarettes
because even the kids
are stressed."
[ Laughter ]
Come on guys, let's put together
one more puzzle.
This one's from @BrianSamelson.
-Wow.
-Wow. Straight up.
-Yeah.
-That was the one I had
the hardest reading.
Just his name.
-A real name, right.
-Brian Samelson.
-For me it was
"And we jiggle like."
'Cause I was thinking, like,
is it that they "jiggle Ike"?
Like, it's a guy named Ike
and, you know people --
-Oh, no, "And we jiggle like."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, but I thought it would be
like Brian Samuelson.
-Yeah.
-Brian Samuelson.
-Yeah, but it's not.
-It's Brian Samelson.
-Yeah, Samelson, just to
throw you off a little bit.
-Yeah, Brian Sameson.
[ Laughter ]
-Sammy.
-Yeah.
-Son.
-Well, maybe...
-That's all your words.
-...it's Brian Sames,
and then that's his son.
[ Laughter ]
-That's Brian Sammy's son?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
That's amazing.
-Yeah.
You got to think, man.
-We got a good one.
This is from Brian Samelson.
-No, Brian.
-Sammy's son.
-Who's Brian? Sammy's son.
-Oh, I got you. Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-This is from Sammy's son.
-Yeah, it's from Sammy's son,
Brian.
[ Laughter ]
-He says,
"New 'Peanuts' special --
'It's a Rapid Test,
Charlie Brown.'"
[ Laughter ]
Only available on Apple TV+.
-Ah!
This last one is from
@atarikari.
Cool.
She says, "Trick or treat,
stay 6 feet, throw me candy
from the street."
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good bop.
That slaps.
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.